hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the markiplier space
program okay
so I've actually done a lot more
research I've watched some many more
videos about actually landing on the
moon and as you can see I've got a
really well not nice a really workable
you know duct-taped together design here
umm I've you using the stock two-stage
Lander that came with the game if you
load up files you can load this up you
can see it's a two-stage Lander I didn't
make that myself but it's got landing
struts and a 2 engine stage system where
you can get on the moon and then
hopefully get back off the moon would be
nice how is in the ever you still need
to get it to the moon what I want
because there's a docking clamp I want
to have a rocket orbiting the moon that
it could get back to it but currently I
don't have a docking thing on this
device this should be more than enough
to get to the moon and back as you can
see the main Rockets are made up of in
three stages the main lifting Rockets I
didn't want to use the big orange ones
because they're too heavy and they cause
problems there's some programming error
in them that they don't work correctly
I'm using the main sail engines just
because this is really heavy and I need
as much power as possible and I'm using
the mid-sized large tanks just because
better fuel to weight ratio in my
opinion and that's just the first stage
it'll be able to get me off the ground
probably not as efficient to the last
one but that's what this middle stage is
for once we're out of the atmosphere
that should take us a long way and the
last one is actually a nuclear rocket
engine which is exceptionally efficient
in space if not very powerful it's not
very powerful but it is efficient so
with that said I have tested this I know
it works so don't I know you're all
looking at me like what the hell is that
amalgamation of nightmares in front of
me it's a spaceship ok it'll work trust
me alt fray and pot ball are gonna get
this done cuz they are the greatest well
not compared to jebediah but there there
are the all rightist okay
is she a theist astronauts we could find
at the time so engine's up as
on three two launch launch right so we
are up and rocketing as you can see
these powerful engines are way more than
we'll ever need to get out of the
atmosphere but that is a good thing
because we can throttle them back right
away and save on fuel so as you can see
we are making good progress we're
already picking up speed too much speed
you want to keep it around 150 as you're
going up to 10,000 so you can save on
fuel and not have to burn through too
much blah blah blah you all heard this a
thousand times before set better than I
could ever say it in dozen different
ways and we're actually running out of
fuel because we're actually running out
of fuel Olli because these Rockets do
not provide them or these Rockets chew
through fuel like nobody's business so
we are about to cross over into the next
stage here already just in time for the
turn and this should mean ok launch
those off we are just about ready to
make our turn here to go out of the
atmosphere into an orbital trajectory
where it's going to pick up some thrust
to correct the errors and as you can see
this this rocket is actually really
stable I'm I'm pretty happy with the way
it has worked so far
it has not been jerky it has not been
crazy it's just been nice and relaxed
smooth ride which is much better than I
can say for my last rockets now how this
will work out when the four engines
because as you go out and they're
propped up like that they have a they
have a tendency to bend in a little bit
and flex the the focus the angle of
thrust towards the top of the thing but
when it's straight up and there's only
one rocket and center and it's top-heavy
it has a habit of wobbling this is
pretty stable because of where the
center of thrust is compared to the rest
of the ship and we actually need to
start going a little bit more angular
here like that gently gently we got a
little bit of a tilt there and that's
just about perfect okay that's about the
best that we could hope for we're doing
great we got lots of fuel we're gonna
get into orbit easily here with this
actually let me crank up so that because
my engine myah my trajectory this is
your trajectory of where your angular
velocity or whatever
some big fancy word that some scientists
came up with they can explain it better
be but this is exactly where the
direction that your ship is currently
headed so I may be thrusting this way
while my ship is drifting more down so I
just need to pick that back up a bit
well we got plenty of fuel to do it
we'll be in space in no time I'm hoping
that I'll have enough fuel actually I'm
going too far bagel I should have been
more up I should have been way more
maybe this design isn't as good as I
think it is probably not but you will
see the magical efficiency of my ship as
soon as it gets to where it needs to go
y'all say you'll all see I know what is
best I am amazing spaceship man I guess
I could have used the big orange engines
I probably would have been better off
for me but it's too late to have regrets
now we're all doing fine I'm just kind
of worried cuz I don't have as much fuel
as I would like we are already well
above so let's cut those engines and
save it for our maneuvers let's be very
careful with our fuel consumption this
time please can we plays please okay or
not our fuel consumption with the
accelerating of time I should not if I
ever have superpowers
I should not control time in any way I
would ruin it for everyone like it was
just like it's magic like some people
just have the happiest moment of their
lives and like I couldn't be happier
zoom smash forward while we're old
oh and then I ruin everyone's life on
earth okay
tonio I should not be trusted with any
superpowers that's basically the gist of
this you know I really do I really do
like the Kerbal space program it's one
of the best games to come along in a
long time it's just the perfect sandbox
game because I I have a long-term love
for any sort of space game because to me
homeworld is one of my favorite games of
all time if you haven't played homeworld
or homo to you need to it's amazing so
let's just get this going we're gonna
need to do an
but just any game that kind of provokes
the imagination it kind of harkens back
to what minecraft was minecraft was an
exceptional game mostly because and you
can see how fuel-efficient I am right
here look at that fuel consumption
oh it's delightful I'm like consuming
nothing it's so great look at that mmm
love it to death okay that's the nuclear
engine for you but it can overheat so
you can't go too powerful all right so
anyway let's get nice and stable there
and we're doing good cooking real low
okay so anyway it's a c-store games it
they don't give you any objective i mean
sure there are things you can do and you
know you can do them like you know that
you can land on the moon but it doesn't
tell you how it doesn't show you how it
doesn't give you a blueprint to do how
it is just what it is and i am in
trouble here because i am going to crash
into the earth at this rate i need to
correct and go more up because we are
way too far down but remember this
doesn't have much thrust but this this
ship is not very heavy so we are
correcting we're going up for trying to
increase April's days which we are not
doing enough so we're gonna have to let
go to straight up at this point I done
goofed a done goofed bad yeah
like I've said before I'm not a
professional anything so don't look to
me for advice on how to do this
correctly because as you can see I am
already screwing up I am already making
a mess of everything and I've barely
gotten anywhere so you can see my ring
morbid is just not good enough
I'm gonna crash into the earth and
you're all gonna laugh and laugh and
laugh thing is that should be getting
closer but it's not I am in trouble
I'm in trouble I'm in trouble
this is bad
Oh the thing is this engine itself is
actually really heavy and that kind of
sucks for when you're trying to get
thrust which I do not have at the moment
don't crash it do plan it get up get up
all right we're gonna we're gonna pan
we're gonna zoom into the future so you
guys don't have to sit through my
horrible plane and you guys can see
afterwards if I correct this or if I
smash into the plan actually at this
rate this stupid engine isn't gonna get
me anywhere ah I five top one second
I'll be back okay everybody we are back
sorry about that I royally boned up that
launched worse than I've ever screwed up
a launch before the floor I've ever okay
I've screwed up worse
but anyway so we're back up and we're
just about to make our burning
trajectory over Moscow and then we're
gonna go on our merry way to the moon to
the moon anyway as you can see we've got
plenty more fuel than we did before
how did you do that you might ask pro
experts super brow maybe I don't know
what I did but I did a lot better so we
got that all shocked in there ready to
rock look at all that fuel we got we did
so much better ten nine potato six
launch
go now look at that ring expand look at
it it's like words yes this is the
greatest moment of Morgan bars with
program history we are the greatest
astronauts to ever grace a nurse other
than a proud day for everyone orders
alone so now that we got this now that
we got the hook now that we got that we
are ready to go look at the looks of
terror on their face it's like they
don't trust me why don't you trust me
because your experience of key force
there you're not even close to the
pass-out range geez I don't even know
how to get inclusive the password ring
I've tried to make rocket-powered death
machines but I just haven't been able to
before actually we're getting a little
away from the April stasis so let's
scoot closer again it's because we're
we're we're rocketing up a bit as
opposed to going over a bit come on
gonna Kenna comma you're lucky I didn't
name you the crass iam exploder you know
got on co-op right there we go little
more come on yeah we got a thrift
busting bush
right easier to maneuver one more thrust
just because the engines add a little
bit to it
get back here get that a post ace is
back here there we go whatever whatever
it's gonna work it's gonna work and
we're gonna be fine we're gonna be just
fine
look at it get away from me get back
here get back here
there we are officially in orbit
congratulations everybody we did it go
Team America or something I don't know
we even still got a little bit of fuel
left I'm surprised I thought that would
have been out of there by now but anyway
let's scooch on over to the next side
nice and easy we got all the time in the
world just have patience be careful
let's do this right now as we a process
we need to do a different type of burn
more meaning we just need to adjust the
dang ship cuz we got so much weight it's
gotta be taking forever
all right here we go and another way
stop slow slow
keep going slow slow slow wha-hey good
enough okay now we can scooch on over
scooch just scoot your bench just a
little bit scooch it scooch it and it's
good enough all right let's target that
moon how the world are we gonna get
there I have no idea I really do not
well let's just take a wild stab at it
cuz that always makes the best decisions
wild stab here we go please don't blow
up please don't die please don't die
don't die kerbals you're my only hope
my only hope of a normal life engines
are about to lose the other one and with
dark okay
now that should be able to get us where
we need to go correct correct
not very quickly it's not why can't I
accelerate while I'm thrusting I can't
stand to sit here and wait as I'm trying
to get this to work it's just just whoa
look at that thing
Oh we're gonna be here forever zoom
through time
hot damn okay wow that took a lot of
time okay now what we're going to do is
very carefully sorry it's our time slow
fast not that faster I'm not touching
that last one now with a ten-foot pole
okay now we're nice and slow because we
might actually get caught in its gravity
and if we do I need to be ready are we
gonna get caught are we gonna get caught
are we gonna get caught are we gonna get
caught looks like we might miss it just
barely okay looks like I'm not okay we
missed it okay so now hopefully it'll
come back around next time when we'll be
able to get into it I don't know I
probably screwed this up again but we
are gonna crash onto that moon if it's
the last thing I do
you know III intend to do a lot of
things with my life okay nice and slow
nice and easy nice and easy nice and
easy nice and easy
nope we might we're gonna miss it again
well holy balls come on where is it come
on come on I'm getting impatient I want
to hit that last one yeah yeah okay
looks like we're gonna get it get it
next time okay so this is gonna be the
one let's just take it okay wait I'm
still in orbit around kerbin holy crap i
missclicked again damn it I missed
I accidentally okay here we go we're
closing in this is gonna be it this is
gonna be the one who's gonna be the one
we're gonna hit the orbit right around
get it we're getting there we're getting
there yeah okay
stop hammer time Bernhard Abbot down
yeah we did it we did it everybody yeah
oh yeah oh my god we
I can't believe it oh wow well we didn't
do anything yet but we're we're here ish
we're kind of little here so what we
need to do see we need to close in on to
the moon how much fuel we get left
plenty lots of fuel we got lots of fuel
left ha ha ha I can't believe it we're
gonna do this we're gonna smash so hard
into the side of the moon which is the
only thing I wanted to do with my life
and now we need to burn too close up
make the moon periapsis go closer to the
moon once we're doing this so that was
that what is that what is that what is
that did some alien beam just cut
through our solar system I don't know
oh god GERD okay now that the surface of
the Moon is actually not at zero you
need to remember that okay so cut it
that'll probably more than close enough
so we just need to scooch our mooch a
little bit closer the moon's gonna come
this way we're still going this way but
we as it's going out we're gonna get
trapped so it's like it's weird you saw
the weird eucalyptus shape and it's
gonna zoom in so you'll see what's going
on you'll see what's going on it's a
little wonky but this is the way physics
kind of works okay now we're closing in
on that so as you can see we are close
to moon and and we go and we need to
start changing because we we right now
we don't have nearly as much speed as we
have before but what we're going to do
is we're going to be pointing our ship
directly adwares that moon we're a seat
all right the ass end of our ship is
pretty much going towards our
destination now what we need to do we
need to do is um somehow slow ourselves
enough that we can land which probably
not gonna I don't know let's just try
this oh we got it you gotta get closer
though cuz at the closer week oh no
we're starting to accelerate now so
we're gonna have to do is we're gonna do
a complete retrograde burn
cuz burning this way will slow us what
will make us kind of fall but at the
same time I'm probably not doing this
right I don't really remember there was
some specific instructions that I was
supposed to follow but I'd totally
forgotten what they were anyway see our
ass this is a retrograde birdies or
pointing our ass towards the way we're
going
basically that's my a non-technical
description of it and what you need to
do then is this slows you down because
when you point back at the earth your
acceleration vector your velocity vector
is pointed in that direction you need to
make an acceleration vector in the
opposite direction so that your velocity
vector will shrink and then eventually
start going up towards your acceleration
vector and as that gets to zero you get
into a manageable speed which is negate
plot it's like floating in the air if
you're at zero see your velocity vector
is at zero but you're kind of your
acceleration vector is kicking you up so
but that only last for a little bit and
then you smash you go the other way but
you don't want it you need to hit that
sweet spot so that you hit the surface
right at zero so that you don't smash or
go the wrong way or start going the
other way it's complicated hard to do
let's do this [ __ ] I just triggered the
other stage why did I do that [ __ ]
whatever
so as you can see we are slowing our
orbit what we don't want to go too slow
or else it'll take forever to get to the
surface so let's just get down to 400
and then we can now scooch our Bouc
closer as you can see this looks scary I
know this looks terrifying
it looks really damp we're gonna land in
that crater okay let's just get to we're
going to a hundred a hundred meters
above the planet or the moon so we just
need to keep our speed manageable so
that we do not smash and as you can see
even now it's looming on the horizon
it's steadily getting bigger this is the
most tense situation we've ever been in
we've everybody ladies and gentlemen
very controlled burn we start our
descent I'm pretty sure I'm not gonna be
doing much acceleration of time here but
I do need to get myself much slower this
is nerve-wracking I'm nervous I'm scared
what's gonna happen are we gonna smack
either way we're gonna hit the moon
somehow we're gonna hit the moon but
it's all depending on how fast we hit
that moon
so yeah about that
we're probably gonna die at least they
look happy look at him look at good Fred
and Mel done they look so happy they do
not even know that their imminent demise
okay now as you can see we're getting
pretty close to the moon now we're
pretty close we're pretty close
eventually we're gonna slow our velocity
vectors so that we are descending in a
straight line up and down but how well
that's gonna happen I do not yet know we
need actually need because is orbit
speed this is some not surface speed
eventually we'll transition to the
surface speed I think
but I'm not exactly sure so so scary
scary scary stop stop burn scary scary
it's a big scary object oh man we're
gonna die we're gonna die we're all
gonna die this is not what you want to
hear from the commander of your mission
die oh my God we're gonna die
okay enough panicking everybody if
jebediah was here he would tell you that
you do not need to panic we have this
under control eventually as we get
closer we are going to detach the back
rocket from this one and it's gonna fall
faster than we are going because we're
gonna slow down and then we will be able
to land question mark oh my god oh god
don't screw it up now mark blurr don't
screw it up now now okay as you can see
we are gently falling down we're being
the the moon has its own acceleration
just like the earth does it's um about a
six of the gravitational acceleration of
Earth so if you think of the thrust
anytime you do thrust you're creating an
acceleration vector because you're
forcing you're creating a force in the
opposite direction of where you're going
so as we gently descend very gently very
gently we're getting very slowly okay at
this point I'm going to detach oh crap
what is that those are solid that's a
solid there's solid rocket boosters on
that let's put that over there and let's
do some quick hot swapping here put that
over there and we need to burn a bit
more we're going way too fast way too
fast and then we need to detach
and just leave these other one oh crap
no no these are in the rug now
okay whatever we're just gonna do this
from here we're gonna land Oh like a
pretty little butterfly with this thing
and then detach I don't know why why is
that can I can I move these right now I
can oh my god I can
holy crap Ola we need to get this down
here so that we can detach these okay
all right detach it
I said detach it there we go okay that
detached oh my god oh my god oh my god
accelerate accelerate we need to slow
down a lot okay too much too much too
much too much okay
all right as you can see we can even see
the moon rocks now so we're gonna point
this like directly and just get barely
enough thrust so that we owe my god well
that's the rocket exploding into the
surface of the Moon but that's okay
okay we're gently gently how do I engage
the landing I don't know how to engage
the landing struts we're gonna have to
land on the engines everybody we're
gonna have to land the agendas because I
don't want to push random buttons and
cause this whole thing to explode we're
just very very slowly very slowly very
very very I'm really lucky that the Sun
is pointing on this side of the side of
the UH okay accelerate more we need to
slow down slow down slow down slow down
slow down
okay okay as you can see okay cut that
let the gravity pull us down a bit more
okay okay we're going down very very
very gently gently ah too much gently
gently gently gently gently gently like
pretty butterfly like pretty butterfly
like a butterfly we're going too far to
the other direction why are we drifting
that way too much too much too
too little too little too little too too
much too little too little too much too
much come on little little we're going
to far the other way no no no if I move
it it'll break I knew it if I knew that
if I touched it would break okay all
right we're done panicking so we did it
everybody yeah we crashed into the moon
Hey those are those are our lander
debris wow that's great huh
whoo be do be good job everybody so
let's just take a moment to appreciate
what happened only the lander struts
survived if I had just been able to land
those I'm pretty sure I could have
gotten it because then like at all if I
hadn't a panicked and started you know I
just needed to correct it a little bit
this way but I didn't because I was
panicking and then I started screaming
we were gonna die and that's exactly
what you don't want to hear so anyway
that was that take it for what it is
next time I'll get it we did our goal
which was crashing into the moon I had
hoped to land by that's the way it goes
you can't land on your engines just
don't do it it's not good don't don't
don't do what I did so anyway thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see
in the next video
you pitch